une cérémonie digne respectueuse et
émouvante c'est incite les familles des
victimes ont souhaité rendre un dernier
hommage à leurs onze disparus
cette commémoration des 20 ans de la
catastrophe du 4 décembre 1999 sera en
effet la dernière réalisé collectivement
un souhait formulé par les familles de
victimes qui espèrent avant tout
aujourd'hui qu'une catastrophe d'une
telle ampleur ne se reproduira plus je
vous propose d'écouter sylvie forest
porte parole du 145 avenue eiffel et
mère de fanny forest disparu le 4
décembre
c'est important les vingt ans toute
façon nous la commémoration c'est par
rapport aux souvenirs la catastrophe
1 donc c'est pas les victimes en soi se
souvient la catastrophe
donc c'était important que l'on puisse
encore le commémorer et dire que voilà
il ya des eu un combat des parents pour
que ça ne se reproduise plus c'est peu
après 16 heures que la cérémonie a
commencé ici autour de la nouvelle stèle
du souvenir qui remplace provisoirement
la précédente ayant été volés est
dégradée elle représentait l'envol de
aux colons pour les onze victimes
et bien cet envol il a été reproduit
aujourd'hui au moyen de ballons et de
cerfs-volants lancés dans le ciel sous
les yeux d'une centaine de personnes
présentes parmi lesquelles françois
rebsamen maire de dijon qui se souvient
de cette nuit d'horreur du 4 décembre
1999 écouter
moi je n'oublie pas parce que j'ai passé
cette nuit dans le froid avec eux cette
nuit de décembre et pour vous dire même
nous avons cru qu'il y avait beaucoup
plus de victimes puisque on fêtait
l'anniversaire d'un jeune heureusement
ils étaient tous sortis à ce moment là
mais ça a été un souvenir terrible
à l'issue de cette cérémonie qui aura
duré un peu plus d'une heure ponctuée
par des chants et des prises de parole
la ville de dijon a invité les personnes
présentes à se rendre quelques mètres
plus loin dans le quartier pour un verre
de l'amitié